الان في منتصف دوار فلسطين نرى حجم الدمار
في هذه
المنطقه دمروا كل شيء مدارس مؤسسات
جوامع كل معالم وملامح المنطقه وشوارعها
تغيرت بشكل
كامل نتحدث عن دمار كبير هائل
جدا
عائلات كانت محاصره ما زالت تحت العلقات
تم قصف منازلها فوق رؤوسها
مؤسسات التابعه لذو الاحتياجات الخاصه تم
قصفها
بالكامل دمار كبير جدا في هذه
المنطقه مازالت النيران مشتعله ايضا في
المنازل يحاول المواطنين تفقد المنطقه
وانتشال الشهداء قدر المستطاع من هذه
المنطقه بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال لاكثر
من شهر كامل وقوات الاحتلال تتواجد في هذه
المنطقه كانوا يكتبون على الحوائط كما نرى
امامنا عبارات وجمل
استفزازيه دمار كبير جدا
وهائل هنا في دوار فلسطين غرب مدينه
غزه بدنا طحين هاتونا خبس ناكل الحشيش
بياكلوا الاولاد قاعدين منهم اللي كانوا
السبب وساكتين العرب منهم لله حسبنا الله
وانت نعم الوكيل فيهم حسبنا الله وانت نعم
الوكيل فيهم نحن الان نتجول في منطقه دوار
فلسطين حيث الدمار الكبير التي خلفته قوات
الاحتلال الشهداء هنا في كل
مكان شهر كامل وقوات الاحتلال تتواجد في
هذه المنطقه انسحبت فجر
اليوم اتى المواطنين ال هنا ليتفقد
المنطقه ومنازلهم وبيوتهم بعد ان تحولت
الى ضمار كبير نتحدث عن مربعات كامله تم
مسحها في هذه
المنطقه تفاجا المواطنين صباح اليوم
بانسحاب قوات الاحتلال منها ليروا حجم
الدمار حجم الخراب الذي خلفوه فيها كان لا
احد يستطيع الوصول الى هذه
المناطق دمار كبير جدا
هنا نتحدث
عن منطقه سكنيه وايضا تحتوي على مؤسسات
دوليه حتى المدارس التابعه لوكاله غوس
وتشغيل اللاجئين ايضا تم قصفها وتدميرها
في هذه
المنطقه دمار كبير
جدا مشاهد
مروعه مساجد مؤسسات منازل مواطنين كل شيء
فيها هذه المنطقه تم قصفه ومسحه نحن الان
نقف امام دوار
فلسطين هنا بالتحديد كانت تتمركز قوات
الاحتلال لاكثر من شهر
كامل كل معالم المنطقه تغيرت بشكل كبير
جراء التجريف والقصف
والمحو المباشر
للمنطقه
[موسيقى]
كلح مازال المواطنين يبحثون عن جسس
الشهداء في
اسفل المنازل المدمره كان هناك العديد من
العائلات التي حوصرت هنا هذا هو جامع
فلسطين الذي نراه امامنا مدمر بشكل
كامل